let's get into that first story we got
this tweet here from libs of tiktok nypd
arrests multiple people including a
young child for trying to enter a museum
without proof of vaccination
this i think shows you the extreme
degrees some of these u.s cities are
willing to go at the same time check
this out
face mask rules and covet passes to end
in england they're also saying that
people can start working from home so
here's my question what what is this
contrast how are we
we're america all right we we declared
independence from from them
because we want freedom and now over
there in the uk they're like yeah we're
going to get rid of all this stuff no
covet passes freedom and then here in
the united states we're split apart by
people who want mandates and want to
push it to the extreme of people who
don't well some people just want to
trample on freedom and squeeze that
lemon to the last drop as of course
cases are going down dramatically the uk
is obviously getting rid of all of their
mandates their lockdowns and
restrictions this is also the the kind
of dichotomy that's happening right now
uh between that hipster clothing company
uh what what is what is it called
car car and starbucks
yuppie hipsters uh wear that all the
time just for the record and that was
appropriated from us rural folks
exactly but but you know the video that
we saw today just shows you the
absurdity i mean we don't even see this
kind of larger push for the vaccine like
we did before because a lot of people
are realizing a lot of bigger truths
here and it wasn't just the united
kingdom it was also the czech republic
that announced that vax mandates are
totally gone in their country because
the president called them nonsense from
the start those are his own words so
we're seeing a big unraveling which
we've been talking about for weeks on
this program i've been saying hey a lot
of things are going to change very
dramatically in 2022 and this is it and
it's happening in front of our eyes and
this to me is the last drop that this
kind of establishment has to squeeze
everything they can out of this tragedy
that unfolded on the world yeah i think
what we're seeing is a representation of
the two different realities that we both
live in right now we have two different
sides of reality for you know large
swaths of the population population
including countries and of course we're
seeing it here in the united states with
states right so we see people by
hundreds of thousands that are fleeing
these blue states places like new york
going to florida going to texas going to
places where they have freedom and they
aren't being told that they can't enter
a store they're going to have a child
arrested this is absurd right so this
this type of stuff is actually going to
drive more and more people to the places
where they will get freedom and it's
going to accelerate the balkanization i
think we're seeing in the united states
right now and there are people who don't
mind living in these in these places
they don't think twice they they they
walk up to their 7-eleven parking lot
and the nice man comes and gives them
their shot and gives them their card and
they're happy with it and there are
celebrities who advocate for that my
position is it always has been you need
sound advice from a trusted medical
professional hey that's what youtube
says you're supposed to say yet for some
reason there are high-profile
celebrities who advocate for you to not
do that but to just go into a 7-eleven
parking lot which is the craziest thing
to me but hey hey look you know what my
position is live and not live if you
live in new york or california or cook
county the chicagoland area and you want
to just you know do whatever do whatever
you want man don't look at me i mean
i'll tell you what i think but people
are going to be staying and other people
are going to be going and that that
hyper polarization we've seen in this
country you mentioned balkanization this
is accelerating it
yeah i think it's inevitable right i
think you know when you have a country
where people live in these two different
spheres these these two different
realities um what do we share in common
anymore what makes us united i mean just
a you know a piece of paper right is
this what makes us united because
there's people that don't even believe
in this anymore and you're holding the
declaration of independence in the
constitution but and i'll point this out
we
people on the right all the time are
like you know tim pool's a liberal or
he's a centrist or center left and i'm
like i don't think those words matter
anymore right because what what this is
really about is do you believe in
reality or not right you you can have a
bunch of views on on religion that i
don't have but we both look at the news
we both break things down and say hey
this thing is true and this thing isn't
right censorship is happening we both
are more likely to believe in aspects of
freedom that the left will completely
ignore or disregard even if we have some
disagreements the left believes i quote
unquote the left you know that the
establishment left they believe outright
falsehoods and they like almost it's
almost like they want to i kind of
russiagate for years jesse smilet
covington all of these things i should
stop and give you pause and be like
maybe that's not correct so we have a
ton of people on this show
just so happens that it is more so the
the colloquial right
and it's not that we're politically
right-wing on this show certainly we all
have varying opinions but it's because
we all agree on what's true so i don't
know what left and right even means at
this point but there if there are two
groups of people that completely view
the world in two different ways they're
not going to work together i feel like
it's more nuanced than do you do you
believe in reality or not more that it's
more the question is how do you perceive
reality and it's different for every
individual although it seems like it's
50 50-ish like most people kind of see
reality in a certain way similarly in
another group i don't even think it's
that simple that it's two groups but
it's like it's so many different groups
of people i i see what you're saying but
what i mean specifically is russia gate
was fake
donald trump did not collude with russia
that was a false narrative from the
press and it seems to be fake yeah seems
to me no it's definitively fake from
what the proof from the evidence we've
see well i've seen it seems to be i'm
not going to lay my hat on any of this
that's i i i think that's
that's actually smart of you because you
you haven't done the research i've done
i i can i can definitively say i've seen
enough that beyond a reasonable doubt it
is true trump did not do this for you
you trust me you've seen some stuff good
point so that's that's actually a fair
assessment but if you're someone who
says after five years of all the lies
how much do they spend on the mueller
investigation it pulls up nothing then
they lie about the ukraine phone call
they lie about everything trump does at
a certain point if you still believe
that and you still believe them it has
to be willful right i think ultimately
what we're seeing here is what is actual
reality right what where reality exists
and then what is the reality that the
establishment regime wants us to believe
exists right and in in the reality that
exists is the truth and in that reality
if you separate the democrat versus
republican stuff and you just talk about
you know basic facts of life most people
whether you're democrat or public you
want to provide for your family you want
to protect your family you want to live
in a safe society where you can go to
the store without having your child
arrested right i think democrat or
republican i think we can agree on that
type of stuff and this divide that they
this this illusion that they have
they're the uniparty they share the
values they have a unified objective the
regime is against us it's us versus the
regime it's not democrat versus
republican because ultimately when you
break down what you know democrats and
republicans as human beings it's human
beings versus these technocratic tyrants
right that is the ultimate you know
dichotomy here of what's going on
absolutely
whatever it lives is absolutely it's
gonna look right
it's absolutely
either you believe in freedom or or the
subjugation of the free human spirit and
there are still some people holding out
but i would say by and large i think a
lot of people are realizing that they
were scammed that they were lied to that
they were not being told the truth these
this video that we just saw happened in
new york city the state we should we
should play it to be honest yeah yeah
well there's
talking there's cursing in there so we
might have to audio but but this is
video of of activists doing the sit-ins
that we literally saw decades ago when
of course segregation was legal here in
the united states discrimination based
on people's own personal medical advice
is absolutely deplorable it's a
disgusting policy that the nypd is
willingly carrying out on beheads of the
state and there's also reports that the
mother of this child also had cps called
on her so it does seem like the state is
trying to punish all these individuals
all these activists standing up for
their personal liberty for their
individual right to be able to
participate in society without needing
to get government permission a domestic
passport system is absolutely insane and
these people are trying to
institutionalize it and luckily that
battle has been lost i think the the big
domino which is the united kingdom has
fallen more dominoes will fall from here
and when you look at the numbers
especially when it comes to cases the uk
when it comes to cases it looks like
it's about one week ahead of the united
states so and and right now in the uk
the cases are dramatically going down
and a lot of people expect the cases to
go down in the united states because
and when that happens this whole game is
going to be unraveled to the american
public how mad do you think people are
going to be when they were like they
said wear masks they send they said get
vacs they said get two shots get three
shots they still locked us down and then
after we did everything they asked they
just release all the lockdowns and
everyone who disobeyed gets to freely
participate
think about the awakening think about
the awakening of that though if you're
someone who got you know the fourth
booster and wore the mask every day and
stayed home and locked down and all that
stuff and all of a sudden this all ends
what does that do to your psyche right i
don't know man you'd think at this point
people would be like maybe i shouldn't
trust the establishment narrative but
they just keep doing it well i think
this is the red pill moment this is it
it's like an evolutionary necessity that
people are exposed to the reality and it
happened to me in 2005 because i was on
the internet making videos and people
are like hey did you know about the
federal reserve did you know about the
military industrial complex and these
were like new words to me i was like oh
no but tell me oh my gosh hey everyone
they're like ian you're crazy but now
it's
it's you cannot deny when when people
are injecting you or forcing you to
coercing you to inject yourself and then
you find out that
fill in the blank you might go nuts well
you find out that it you know in the uk
the vax passport's done yeah so there
were people who were told if you want to
participate and go to bars and
restaurants you have to do this and they
said okay and now a few months later
they go actually nah scrap it actually
it's a leslie
it's it's not about that for me it's not
about the science it's not about the
medical stuff that's but that's your
personal business it's the people who
are told if you want to go out to eat
you have to do what we tell you to do
and they did i don't care if it's wear a
fuzzy hat or get a vaccine the point is
the people who obeyed the government
ultimately end up realizing they
shouldn't have they should have done
what was right for them
and if that means going to a doctor and
you know we've had a lot of people on
the show who have been vaccinated
they're older yeah and their doctors
advised it
there's a lot of people who probably
don't care about this and that's the
other important thing you're going to
see a lot of people on the left being
like oh they're so worked up no no i
recognize that a good portion of people
probably went to their doctor got a
vaccine and said have a nice day and
never thought twice but there are a lot
of people who are who are just doing
whatever they're told by the state when
they realize
i'll give you an example
there's that guy in a store stalking a
woman screaming is anyone else mad that
we all have to wear masks and she isn't
wearing one
that's exactly who i'm talking about
those people are gonna lose it when
they're like no
but i did what i was told yeah they need
um they're gonna need like a safe place
to to regain sanity so there'll be it's
an opportunity to make fun of people and
be like you stupid idiot look how you
fell for that you more and just
make people so angry and hateful but
ultimately i think if we can be
forgiving and kind i was just going to
stay it's an opportunity for empathy
because if we show them empathy then
they will be more open to our ideas and
saying listen
listen next time you know you call this
conspiracy theorist you called us you
know uh extremists and all this stuff
and anti-science and all this stuff and
now you've woken up to this well maybe
next time they'll listen to us if we
show them a little bit of empathy this
time i think that has a powerful effect
i think a lot of people are going to go
crazy i think those feelings are going
to be exacerbated specifically when it
comes to individuals who are still
locked down i use that word
i know exactly what i'm doing here i
posted i posted a meme on my instagram
page showing a confused blond-haired
bare-chested australian on barbed wire
looking confused and it says australians
watching the uk remove all mask mandates
and and
there's going to be a feeling in
australia in the netherlands being like
why are we still doing this when the
rest of the world didn't do this and i
truly do believe what florida did during
this entire saga was absolutely crucial
when it came to defeating the mandates
and lockdowns here in the united states
if it wasn't for florida if it wasn't
for governor desantis texas followed him
other states followed his lead
specifically saying we're not even going
to implement this here in the first
place and because of that this is why i
think it wasn't uh you know set into
play all throughout the united states
because of him standing up and saying no
other states are saying no right now
other countries are saying no right now
and other countries are going to be
looking on be like hey they get to have
some freedom we want some of that too
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you